dans le confinement confidences
tendresse contre la pandémie occupe tous
les esprits
sans nier la gravité de la situation
certains sont d'avis que mieux vaut en
rire que d'en pleurer pour se changer
les idées
ils se tournent vers l'internet j'essaie
de parler de la situation à chaque fois
de partir de choses convient le tout le
monde et puis de faire l'humour avec ça
c'est tout ce que je peux faire c'est la
seule façon pour moi de contribuer
savez-vous qu est ce qui arrive quand je
mets de la vodka dans ma bière mais on
peut dire que ma coronavirus la crise
actuelle sont des stimuler l'industrie
du mot en juger par l'abondance de
contenu en ce moment c'est qu'on vi et
ses immenses puisqu'il sans précédent
que des gens qui fiche devant samuel
jamais été aussi créative important
certaines capsules sont devenue virale
et de nouveaux rendez-vous sont imposés
c'est le le côté présumé plus
authentique que les gens ont
l'impression de vraiment passé un moment
avec quelqu'un les artistes qui viennent
aussi font par la maison fait qu'ils
sont comme prématurée elle très
chaleureux à défaut de pouvoir partager
la scène dans le clip de they midi les
humoristes partagent l'écran
virtuellement je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose de très fraternel le bain et de
très positif depuis quelques temps
stéphane rousseau s'était tourné vers
l'art visuel mais la crise actuelle le
ramener à ses premières amours
j'ai envie de renouer avec l'humour je
trouve que ça me donnait comme un petit
pin j'ai envie de j'ai vraiment envie de
remonter sur scène puis de faire rire
les gens
de tout temps l'umoa et est une valeur
refuge qui ne connaît pas la crise on
parle de la deuxième en septembre 2001
que l'on parle des grandes pandémies
qu'on est en travers l'histoire même de
la révolution française la révolution
bolchévique les 13 d'animaux sont
toujours là chaque fois que l'être
humain doit passer à travers quelque
chose de traumatisant le move afin ce
bon ça fait offrir on s'est passé quoi
l'humour en ligne permet d'égayer le
confinement mais rien ne remplace un fou
rire contagieux kan a dû reprendre je
pense pas devenu une sensation numérique
je pense que juste le terme sensation
numérique n'existe même pas non non j'ai
travaillé sur les piscines a dit
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal